though team ninja has certainly kept
busy over the years churning out
fast-paced action games and fighting
titles in Rapid succession it's been a
few years since the studio has unveiled
a new IP however all that changes with
woe long Fallen Dynasty the next big
project from the Japanese developer
revealed last summer during the Xbox and
Bethesda games showcase or long Fallen
Dynasty is a souls-like action RPG based
on Lao guanjong's 14th century
historical novel Romance of the Three
Kingdoms however much like team ninjas
Neo or long Fallen Dynasty offers a
Fantastical take on ancient history
embellishing well-known stories with
demonic forces and mythical beings with
neo-director fumihiko yasuda and
bloodborne producer masaka yamagiwa at
the helm of wo long it's no surprise the
upcoming game is one of the most
anticipated of 2023. here's everything
you need to know about olong Fallen
Dynasty
the upcoming action on PG is set in
China during 184 A.D just before the
fall of the Han Dynasty and the start of
the Three Kingdoms period as such the
game also features several legendary
figures of the time including guanyu
Zhang FEI Zhao Yoon and lubu however
this is not your average retelling of
ancient Chinese history according to
team ninja war long Fallen Dynasty is a
dark fantasy one where players must ward
off demons as they fight for survival
team ninja also elaborated on The Game's
name revealing a fair bit about
warlong's story in the process according
to the studio quote wo long refers to a
crouching dragon which also refers to a
hero or person of greatness who is not
yet known this is the story of officers
who will later become Heroes during
their unknown period And also the story
of a protagonist's rise being a nobody
[Music]
in war long Fallen Dynasty players are
given the chance to fully customize not
only how their character looks but how
they control as well after creating a
character players will get the option to
select one of five phases or combat
Styles these ultimately dictate a
character's stats starting spells and
what divine beasts will Aid them each
phase has a unique Focus metal is for
debuffing enemies wood is healing and
support water is stealth fire is attack
and Earth is defense as you level up
your character over time you are free to
invest experience in any of the five
elements so if you ultimately want to
spec out a character whose Focus differs
from your starting phase you are able to
do so additionally players will also
have free reign to select what weapon
they'd like to use from a wide
collection of glaves Sabers swords and
more with each weapon having different
strengths and weaknesses that play into
the different phases core to wo long
Fallen Dynasty's gameplay is its morale
system which indicates the strength of
both your character and your opponents
by defeating enemies with a higher
morale rank than your character your own
morale increases faster and more
valuable items will be dropped
uncovering new checkpoints locks in the
base morale rank for both the player and
enemies and if the player is defeated
their morale rank will reset to that
Baseline when they awaken at their most
recently discovered checkpoint combat in
Wollongong will be based on traditional
martial arts according to team ninja and
will emphasize graceful movement and
deflection your character has a spirit
meter with an orange negative side and
blue positive side when you boot up the
game the meter will be neutral neither
side filled successful strikes on
enemies will net you positive spirit as
you use special abilities block or Dodge
attacks or take hits from enemies that
positive spirit will be chipped away
crossing over into the negative if you
don't get any successful hits on an
opponent if the negative side fills up
your character is staggered which will
reset the meter to neutral but leave you
open to attacks for a brief moment with
no ability to defend yourself enemies
also have their own Spirit meters that
work similarly to the players and
successfully pushing opponents gauges
into the negative will leave them open
for a takedown once filled certain
attacks from enemies can be counted as
they wind up their attack if a red
energy fissure appears over the center
of them blocking the following attack at
the moment it hits will deflect the
enemy massively negating their Spirit
meter and leaving them open to a big
counter-attack from you or possibly even
a lethal takedown if they are a lower
level opponent or their health is
depleted enough in gamespot's woe long
Fallen Dynasty preview philhorn short
praised the game's combat the Speedy
gameplay the variety of attack options
and the push and pull nature of the
spirit system make wol long feel like a
fresh spin on souls-like games it
captures the difficulty and skill
players like about the genre while
pushing a different kind of action game
feel team ninja has stated warlong
Fallen Dynasty will be its most
challenging game yet however this did
not stop the studio from opting out of
including difficulty settings though the
game might not have difficulty settings
there is a silver lining in the game's
multiplayer option which grants players
the ability to summon a friend during
tough battles
wo long Fallen Dynasty is set to release
on PlayStation 4 PlayStation 5 Xbox One
Xbox series X and S and PC on March 3rd
2023 if you're an Xbox game pass
subscriber you can look forward to the
title hitting the subscription service
on day one there are two versions of
warlong Fallen Dynasty available for
pre-order standard edition and deluxe
edition if pre-ordered both versions
come with the Juke and by who armor sets
the deluxe edition also includes a
digital art book digital mini soundtrack
and the game's season pass complete with
the King long armor set wo long Fallen
Dynasty seems to be taking the tried and
true Souls like formula and giving it a
unique twist with its Spirit meter
morale system and phases stay tuned to
Gamespot for our full review and
additional coverage around the game
[Music]
foreign